[موسيقى]
هذه هي المره الاولى التي يزور فيها شمال
اسماعيل مع عائلته السعوديه ليقضوا فيها
احدى عطلاتهم العائله التي تقيم في
بريطانيا منذ 23 عاما وان قامت بزياره
عشرات الدول بقصد السياحه يفضلون التنقل
بسياره مستقله للاستمتاع بتفاصيل اكثر عن
البلدان التي يزورون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شمال وعائلته يرون بان زياره السعوديه
فريده سواء من ناحيه اجراءات استخراج
التاشيره السياحيه ومن خلال مشاهداتهم في
الرياض التي لاقت اعجابهم بفعالياتها
الشتويه وتنوع الماكولات في مطاعمها
الفاخره والله جو جو الطيب حلو شتاء داخل
العالم
بالصب وليفار بوليفار سيتي الالعاب ما شاء
الله يعني
انبسطنا وان شاء الله ما يكون اول واخر
جيرين كل زياره متعدده يعني نحاول عطلات
المدرسه
صوفيا بس ما شفنا مثل هذه المتجه يعني
متحمسين انه نشوف اكثر الاماكن الاكثر
15 يوما امامهم في السعوديه
يخططون خلالها لزياره العديد من المدن
المدرجه على دليل شتاء السعوديه هذا العام
حيث يتجهون بعد الرياض الى جده والعلا ثم
الاحساء فالدليل يوفر كامل المعلومات التي
يحتاجها السياح عند زيارتهم للسعوديه مثل
المطاعم وابرز الفعاليات الترفيهيه
والثقافيه
لكل مدينه
[موسيقى]
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه